so we know that housing is a real source
of anxiety for the many in the UK today
but what our new research shows is that
it's young people who are truly at the
sharp end of the housing crisis we've
seen affordability decrease over time
generation on generation but it's really
young people who today are really
suffering a lot of older people would
say well hang on we had it pretty bad
too in that you know someone in their
60s and 70s today would probably have
had to have built up a credit record
with a Building Society or a bank over
many years before they were even allowed
a home loan it's far easier to obtain
credit for house purchases now isn't it
that's true I mean it's the
intergenerational picture it is is not
simple it's absolutely true that that
many older people who are homeowners
today face for example very high
interest rates when they were young and
that was definitely a tax on their
incomes of course what today's young
people face in contrast is not high
interest rates but very high house
prices we estimate that it takes the
average young family today 19 years to
say for a mortgage 20 years ago that was
three years of course another thing that
older people say is it's easier for
young people and data by essential goods
I mean the cost of food relative to
wages has fallen very very dramatically
household appliances again in the old
days you had to save up for months on
end to buy things like a fridge freezer
whereas such commodities are relatively
cheap these days well it's true that the
costs of different goods obviously
change over time and our kind of
consumption patterns change over time
too and of course housing is an absolute
essential we all have to have a home
fundamentally and so the extent to which
housing acts as a tax on our income is
is really important for our living
standards we perhaps getting a bit too
carried away with the notion of
homeownership I'm in it if you take
Germany for example their whole new
image ownership rates about 51% compared
with 63% here I mean should we not just
accept not everyone is going to be able
to buy a home in future well it's
certainly true that you can achieve
security and you can achieve
affordability in different ten years
other than the homeownership Germany is
a perfect example of where many people
do that and many people decide to rent
for the whole of their lives and we
to recognize of course two key things in
the UK the first is that we have a very
unregulated private rented sector and
that means for example that you can be
given notice with only two months before
you have to leave a property the second
thing is that in the UK holding a home
is a key way that people build up an
asset in Germany people have other
options for ways to make wealth what
about some of the recent changes in
regulation on by - lets properties I'm
in George Osborne one of the reasons
that he did that was to try and free up
properties that were currently owned by
by - that landlords for sale on the
market do you think that's had any
impact in alleviating the situation well
dumping off by Tula is probably not a
bad idea but if the truth of the matter
is that a lot of buy-to-let properties
are often at the bottom end of the
market I think there's a real question
about what happens if landlords leave
that market where are people on very
very low incomes going to be able to
live so is the answer simply then just
to just build more homes presumably well
building more homes is absolutely part
of the solution but then other things we
could look at - we could look at
regulating the private rented sector for
example we could look at institutional
investment in the private rented sector
we do need to recognise that there's all
kinds of ways that people can achieve
the security and affordability that they
desire from their home in different ways
you